expect to fail expect to suck especially
if it's your first time if it's your
first time speaking on stage for example
you're not going to be great you're not
going to be less brown you're not going
to be Tony Robbins you're not going to
be Brenda sharp you're not going to be
great it's your first time your first
video you're not going to be great it's
why I kept my first video up on my
channel too you can go back and watch it
the first time you do it you're not
gonna be great this is one of the
biggest fallacies in human thinking is
we expect to be great the first time we
do something and if we're not great we
don't do it anymore as kids we learned
that when we fail we get up and we try
again as adults though we're so
terrified of failing that we don't try
most things and then we have this
constant thought in our mind that we
know we're capable of more but we're too
afraid to go up and start and so expect
to fail